hi it's atom bernath here at the true
brand martial digital hub and today i'm
testing out a viral tik tok trend of
ramen crusted grilled cheese yes that's
right this grilled cheese is full of not
one not two but three types of cheese
inside that makes it super gooey six
slices per sandwich let's get cooking
all right over here i have my two slices
of white bread we're gonna hit it with
some cheddar some monster
some colby jack even more cheddar even
more monster and even more
colby jack right there sandwich that up
now you could just enjoy it like this
but no no no it's time to crazify it
i've got my ramen i've got my weapon of
choice and just
go at it just smack
the ramen with your rolling pin and as
you can see it is now the perfect size
for coating our grilled cheese take your
grilled cheese start off in the batter
getting that just fully fully coated as
much as possible sticking it together
and then just coat it in oh god it's
slipping coat it in your ramen so just
really get that coated this can add a
nice crunch little a little bit of
texture on the outside if you will and
then i'm now going to place it into my
make believe deep fryer right over here
there you go you have the delicious
ramen crusted grilled cheese i'm just
going to cut this all around and look at
that cheese pull
whoa
look at that look at that look at that
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
whoa whoa whoa it's how low can you go
can you go down oh it could go low oh
wow oh wow okay that is just like a
rainbow of cheese
oh hold on
that is crispy crazy ambulatory
drew i think you're gonna love this let
me know if you tried and comment down
below if you're watching what do you
think are you gonna try this you're not
gonna try is it worth the hype is it not
i would love to hear in the comments
[Music]